HEOW I CE
GOVERNOR, THANK YOU H FO
TATE'SW JUSTERU AND THE FO P
OF THIS TTTHS THE 20ASTOSO WHATE
UR STATE AND TL REPUBLICAN PARTY
>> WELL, THE NAMES
SHR  WNGFO REAN, SHE'SPRO-GUN, C
FRESH, NEW LEADER FOR PERSONANO
OF ARIZOOPPONE,  OER
S NO RESEMBLANCE.
CAER
THAN ABE TIME ST 3
THE NATIONALVERSAT
, AS I ELECTIOINCARE
FOER
PRESIDENT,N LARGE PART,
YLSON STARTED FROMGGED BY HER
BLICANERNORSIORIE THE GENERAL ES
TH ALL 2 ROLES
TO B
E  GBUOFPUBLICANGOAPPE BE VERYO.
E  MAJITICAN CONFERENCE IN THE
E TES RED.WE'RE ON OFFENSE ALL .
RT.
WETAINLY DON'T NDIDTO STATES WH
IVE AND GEOD CANDIDATE OVER THF.
H
IN PENNSYLVAFOTH
GORN RACE.
WILL YOU SUPPORT HIM OR IN
THAT LOST CAUSE?
>> NO, DIDN'T SAY LOSTNYOR G YO-
>> IT'S A LONG WAYS --
WTHE RGM INLVR  L
F,
MAG AT THE
RESOURS E DON'T
KNOW WHAD OCTOR G TO DON'T KNOWH
CHARSARRY HOGAN IN
GLENN YOUNIN IN VIRGINIA IG TO T
DECISIONS TAEDA BASIS ON
HOE SUCCESS AND
WES WHER NUMBERS, BUTHO S THE C.
COITWIN THE ET ME ASK YOU ON A T
E 2020ION WA
OLN YOUR HOM
THE GOVERNOR'S MANSIINLVANIA, TN
THAT THE PEOPLE OF
ANY  GOVERR N PEOPLEHAT SMALSI R
SR
I ALSO THINK THIS ELECTION
SHOULD BE ABT E .N'HOULD THINK
RE20S ABOUE 2022 ECLE. SE RGA IS
TOLECT R
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE GOG N THI
RUSTYANUARYh.YOUR STATE HSEPEAD
STIFIED BEFORE THAT COMMIT
RECT PRESSURE
MP BEA ME RES MR ON THIS
YOU BELVENUh OR
DISQUALIFYIM FORNG
ICE? DANA, I CONMNED J
E HELD  E
ACCOUNTABLE.
IN OUR SYSTEM, THIS P  THE
VOTERSWH
SO MANY PEOPLE TALK
I  FS ESTT ALHYTH
TURN TPA ANDO
THE COUNTRYONSERVATIVE
TT
POSSIBLE PEOPLE ELD  2022.
E  ARI
Y  IIN
WILL YOU SUPPORT
>> I TWILLOPTIONS 2024 IMARY I.
AN SOMEBODY WH
THAT GENERAL ELECTN I
N ,
L ELECS THREPUBLICAN PAR'SET'S
REALLY IMPORNT
VOTERS ARE TALKIBOUT A
THINKIPRICESGAICYOURTA
ARIZONA ARE STILL AT
AVERAGE.
N WANTS A
HOAT STALL YOUUPPORT TEMPORARI
TAX IN THE NT PASSEDST
DEOR
NT BIDFLYING TO THE MIDDLE
WHAT HE COULDOWORKH ULD DO IENPP
GY APROVIDE Y OF FOSFUS, ANDOLI.
HE'S GO MAKET DECINOT GOING TO G
IN ARIZONAHAK OR PUTS MY SUCCES
A TERRIBLE SPOT E GOING TO HAVEA
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE AS WELL. R
ARIZONA?PORTBE
>> LISTEN,KN
SIDERED THNUMBER
IFE STATE IN
WAF THE SUPREM
TI
STATES.W THATNETHE OR LD THE IN
IS ATTORNENERAL.
LTIMATEL
SH C TDG
PL>> D
INCEST.
THHAT I REMAIN
OGRAM INTOAW LY STUDEN YOU PAY R
CRITICS SAY IT WL FUNNEL S
DOLLAR WILRD PRIVATE
SCHOOLS.
OULD W W
CAN AFVATE SL,E ERS?
>> ARIZONA IW THE GOLDRD FORDUCE
ZONTS.S P FOR L
TODATHY ESM OUT THFAMIRSGOLIIN E
STANLH
AND WON'T LET MINORITIES OUT.E E
FREE.
TRAPPN FAIL
ABLE TLEAR GLS AND NOW T A WAY B
THEC THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
I
I ENCOURAGE ALL MYNORS
BO RDEMOCR
TAKE THIS BILLARIZONA, TAKE
EDUCATIOL SAVINGS ACTS
S ACCE SO THEY CAN GET
THE EDUC THEIRARENTS'
OVS ON MAKING SURE
E S THOSE WHO HAVE WEAOCUS THEC
FUG  THEM?
ICUNTHY FAMILIESN IS ABOUTEDUCA
OPPORTUNITY FOALL OF OURSTUDENTU
FAMILIES.
I  TS  THEAY
R AMERICAN 12
O AMERICA.
H LEARNING SOIN
SCCIVICS, THREADING,